[Musique]
mon brave mésange nommé Carlos Colon
pour découvrir l'amérique s barc Sur un
Gaillon va va fa beau fait beau poura
poura ciao ciao en cherchant la terre
nouvelle IL connu bien des ennuis en ce
temps les caravelles volent moins haut
qu'aujourd'hui
faisait pitié ma mère de voir la pauvre
vigie en haut du mar de misère faci
Encore rassemble
bougie va j'ai Le vertige mais bon s va
c'est B sa va tomber mais enfin va pas
Voon pas en fras qu'on pourra Ciao on
était mieux bordeaux un jour dans un
ciel magique les mouettes ont fait
coucou IL s'est dit c'est l'amérique
more c'était pas du tout c'était l'Au
plage blonde o les filles bou font la
cour IL cherchait le nouveau monde IL
j'avais trouvé l'amour va mon bahtim va
pas mais va c'est beau pour la saison
fait même un peu chaud cour J su J reste
pip pour Ciao Je veux pas retourner
bordeaux on peut même dire que c'est
extra Plus de 60 Au dessus zé Carlos
colon est vraiment le roi Ciao Non mais
passer
Ciao va mon bent va pas mais va pour la
saison fait même un peu chaud
Je suis
p Je pas tourner bordeau Non Non va on
peut même dire que c'est ext Plus de zé
car c'est vraiment le
ro
step B va pas mais va pour la saison même
un
ch